[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 9 juin voici les
titres de l'actualité locale avec la
crise sanitaire et le confinement
engendrer beaucoup d'entreprises ont
connu une baisse d'activité
d'autres au contraire ont été fortement
sollicités c'est le cas de cette société
installée à trappes qui produit
notamment des parois mobiles très
demandé en ce moment il a rouvert ses
portes samedi le château de versailles a
accueilli ses premiers visiteurs depuis
presque trois mois un parc un château
accessible uniquement sur réservation
horaires pour limiter les flux quel est
le premier bilan éléments de réponse et
puis cette yvelinoise va représenter le
département à ce concours de beauté
adeline cortesi figurera parmi les
candidates pour devenir nice
international en juillet prochain
son portrait à la fin de cette édition
mais avant de développer ces titres à un
plan de relance pour faire face aux
difficultés rencontrées par le secteur
de l'aéronautique
il a été annoncé et présenté ce matin
par le gouvernement au total 15
milliards d'euros dès dettes
investissement et de prêts garantis par
l'état pour les acteurs de la filière
prolongement des aides création de fonds
d'investissement pour les pme et eti ou
encore favoriser la recherche et le
développement orienté vers la transition
environnementale
un plan dont va bénéficier la pme su
mécatronique basée à magny-les-hameaux
spécialisé dans l'industrie de tournage
et de fraisage c'est un sous traitant de
safran et thales directement impactés
par la crise sanitaire écouter son
directeur interrogé par nicolas landry
la bonne chose c'est que le chômage
partiel ou l'activité partielle sera re
prolonger maintenant quand il parle de
longue durée on ne fait pas maintenant
j'ai entendu dire que l'idée d'avoir des
milliards débloqués pour renforcer les
capitaux propres des entreprises la
fanfare qui soit un peu plus précis
l'inde ans parce que moi d'après mes
sources
on avait parlé d' aerofund numéro 4 donc
c'est des fonds participatif
effectivement du bic fort qu'on appelle
airbus dassault safran et thales et qui
rentreraient dans le capital des
sociétés
maintenant faut savoir qu'yves
entrée au capital ou pas quoi je trouve
que c'est un peu dangereux évidemment on
connaît pas la finalité de femmes avec
l'arrêt des salons et festivals cette
entreprise basée à trappes spécialisée
dans l'impression numérique craignaient
une baisse d'activité seulement le
déconfinement à intensifier la demande
en signalétique et autres supports et il
a fallu s'adapter à cette nouvelle
demande le reportage de marie ligne à
pishin dans cette salle de crossfit
trappistes avait ouvert ses portes en
février dernier mais au bout d'un mois
d'exercice les appareils sont restés
orphelins de sportifs confinement oblige
alors pour pouvoir rouvrir le plus vite
possible le gérant a fait installer des
parois mobiles et des marquages au sol
l'objectif c'est d'être prêt avant la
date donc on est en train de voir on
travaille dessus encore et toujours pour
être prêt au maximum et pour éviter
comment dire d'être bloqués par les
strates et les restrictions de l'état
donc on est on est déjà sur
l'anticipation c'est paroisse et cette
signalétique elles ont été fabriquées
dans cet atelier
lagence districom spécialisée dans
l'impression numérique installé à
trappes depuis 15 ans a vu son activité
augmenter en cette période de
déconfinement dans les quinze premiers
jours donc des fermetures de
l'entreprise
on a fait donc des réunions
par internet et ce qui nous a permis
donc de mettre en place une stratégie
pour pour affronter le co vide donc le
souhait de districom ça a été vraiment
de proposer un catalogue complet où on
avait plus de 45 pages de produits
destinés aux co vide
l'entreprise est également modifier
certaines habitudes de travail pour
pouvoir répondre à la demande le plus
vite possible avec par exemple la
création d'un site internet permettant
aux clients de faire un premier devis en
ligne avant d'entrer en contact avec
l'entreprise
on s'est aperçu que la demande liée aux
qu'ovide c'était de pouvoir être livrés
très vite d'être livrés sur des produits
qui soient pas forcément des produits
standardisés mais qu'ils puissent est
des produits personnalisés
et c'est surtout cette capacité de
réagir entre la demande du client et la
livraison d'être à j + 1 j + 2 au grand
maximum quand on est en province donc
c'est vrai que ça nous a obligés à
réinventer notre mode de production
une fois les installations que j'ai
terminé l'entreprise revient à ses
fondamentaux et accompagne les besoins
en communication et autres enseignes
nécessaires à la reprise économique de
leurs clients
si cet épisode épidémique a freiné une
partie de la suite et liées à
l'événementiel en s'adaptant cette
entreprise a pu gagner de nouveaux
clients publics comme privés un
programme de recherches exceptionnel
dédié à la coved 19 il a été lancée par
l'université paris saclay donc fait
partie pour rappel uvs qu grâce à l'aide
de partenaires des fonds seront
débloqués 27 projets sélectionnés en
interne vont pouvoir être financés pour
un budget total de plus de 900000 euros
un premier axe concernera la
participation à l'effort de recherche
internationale pour contribuer à mieux
maîtriser l'épidémie et en limiter les
conséquences sanitaires
l'autre volet vise à anticiper les
recherches a lancé au sortir de la crise
pour construire le monde de demain
le point à présent sur l'épidémie de
coronavirus dans les yvelines l'acolyte
19 à fait à 504 victimes dans les
hôpitaux du territoire
soit deux décès supplémentaires en 24
heures elle les hospitalisations qui
était tir de 500 une
ont légèrement augmenté plus une entre
dimanche et lundi 31 passion était
toujours placé en réanimation hier mardi
soit un cas en moins depuis dimanche
et depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
1991 personnes ont été guéries d'une
forme sévère de lakovic 19 la page
dédiée aux élections municipales second
tour au programme le 28 juin prochain
pour 45 communes des yvelines aux
clayes-sous-bois trois candidats se font
face pour devenir le maire de la ville
parmi eux nicolas huet de liste un autre
projet pour les clayes sous bois qui
s'est classé deuxième au premier tour du
scrutin nous lui avons donné deux
minutes pour vous convaincre regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean notre liste est un collectif
citoyen qui est travail des jeux
désormais depuis un an maintenant et qui
est une équipe totalement soudés
cohérente renouvelé et dynamique et qui
est à l'image de notre ville et qui
porte un projet d'avenir pour la commune
[Applaudissements]
or point phare il pourrait y en avoir
plusieurs
mais notre action sera basée avant tout
sur la concertation tout au long de
notre mandat et sur les projets priorité
que nous avançons maintenant depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
telle la transition écologique la
proximité la solidarité et la
convivialité de soutien à l'économie
locale et à l'emploi et bien entendu une
véritable démocratie participative est
renouvelée des axes qui répondront à
tous jeunes seniors et toutes les
familles à la crise que nous venons de
traverser a quelque peu rebattu les
cartes par rapport aux 15 mars dernier
bien entendu nous aurions amener
quelques priorités différentes
mais là il me semble urgent et
nécessaire dans la période que nous
vivons est pour eux le les mois à venir
des nôtres dès notre installation le 29
juin prochain d'installer une commission
et économique et de l'emploi ouverte à
tous les professionnels les entreprises
chrétienne pour relancer de manière
coordonnée notre notre économie locale
de proximité mettre en place une
organisation locale du plan du plan
local par de santé et du handicap avec
les professionnels de santé de la
commune et bien entendu mettre une
veille d'une cellule de veille pardon
sanitaires sur la possible canicule qui
pourraient être des nôtres
malheureusement cet été
[Applaudissements]
même exercice cette fois ci à voisins le
bretonneux ou trois candidats ou s'ils
sont qualifiés pour le second tour
béatrice pire à tête de liste d' avec
vos voisins avance est arrivé en
troisième position le 15 mars dernier
présentation également en deux minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord toute l'équipe et moi même avons
une pensée en cette période de crise
sanitaire pour toutes celles et tous
ceux qui nous regardent aujourd'hui est
le plus de notre équipe c'est une de
l'empathie aussi de l'énergie parce que
moi je suis nouvelle en politique et
donc c'est quelque chose de différent
pour moi et c'est ce qui fait le plus de
notre équipe
le point fort de notre programme qui
nous différencie des deux autres listes
de la ville c'est ce que nous avons
appelé l'assemblée vie sinoise notre
ville va être amené à prendre des
décisions très importantes pour son
avenir et nous pensons qu'il est
important de composer une assemblée vie
chinoise qui rassemble non seulement des
conseils de quartier mais aussi des
habitants des associations des
commerçants pour prendre les décisions
stratégiques qui vont impacter la ville
sur les décennies à venir
[Applaudissements]
après cette crise
on sent bien que il faut inventer le
monde d'après le monde d'après est
toujours lié à des choix politiques des
choix politiques qui se reflète par des
choix budgétaires et la première
décision sera sur les affectations
budgétaires notamment une étude de du
budget défini pour le centre communal
d'action sociale le ccas
car la crise nous a montré que après cet
élan de solidarité que nous avons vécu
des personnes de la ville sont quand
même en en situation de difficulté nous
devons les accompagner
[Applaudissements]
et pour respecter les gestes barrière la
liste de béatrice pira organise une
campagne vélo vous pourrez voir les
colistiers a sillonné la ville samedi
pour informer sur leurs programmes dans
l'actualité également ce geste des
résidences yvelines essonne le bailleur
qui gère 32 mille logements sur les deux
départements a mis en place une caisse
de solidarité
l'objectif effectuer une remise
exceptionnelle en faveur des locataires
qui ont subi une perte de salaire suite
à la crise sanitaire et décision qui
fait suite à la hausse du montant global
des impayés de loyer selon le bailleur
ni l'actif locataires du parc sont
actuellement en difficulté de paiement
les transports je vous le disais hier
qu'ils reprennent peu à peu un trafic
normal mais peut-être que vous voulez
vous orienter plutôt vers une location
de vélos la vélostation de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisait une
distribution de kits pour rouler en
toute sécurité
c'était en gare de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux en
partenariat avec la municipalité 150 ont
été ainsi distribués un kit comportant
un gilet jaune et un brassard pour être
bien visible sur son vélo l'occasion
aussi de sensibiliser de faire la
promotion de ce service la vélostation
qui a ouvert à fin 2017 à proximité de
la gare les propos recueillis au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude
on voit là en distribuant les gilets qu'
il ya un certain nombre d'usagers qui
connaissent la vélostation et pour
certains qu'ils utilisent
je discutais avec le gestionnaire delà
de la vélostation qui m'expliquait que
il ya des réparations qui se font là et
qui sont programmés jusqu'au mois d'août
donc grand succès ça répond à un vrai
besoin sur de la population donc c'est
un très très bel outil offert aux
habitants de montigné de 50 à la
vélostation se divise en 3 trois
divisions
la première consiste à louer des vélos
de
des vélos de ville de vélos en location
la deuxième donc qui consiste à allouer
des places de parking sécurisé donc des
places de consignes et la troisième un
pôle réparation de vélos et si vous
souhaitez louer garer ou faire réparer
votre vélo plus d'informations sur le
site internet de la vélostation de saint
quentin en yvelines qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran
après on semaine 100 visiteurs le
château le plus célèbre de france a
rouvert ses grilles ce week-end jauge
réduite parcours pensée réservation le
château de versailles a bien sûr
souffert financièrement de la situation
mélanie poké mathilde et demi ont
rencontré catherine pégard la président
du château du musée et du domaine
national de versailles regarder
catherine pégard bonjour le château et
le domaine on peut accueillir leurs
premiers visiteurs ce samedi 6 juin
j'imagine que pour toutes les équipes
s'étaient déjà un grand soulagement
ouais c'était un soulagement c'était
aussi une grande joie de pouvoir rouvrir
ce château après je crois à 82 jours de
fermeture et ici je crois qu'on aime
partager tous ce même sentiment de voir
satisfaites une attente qui avait
commencé le jour même de la fermeture
c'est à dire le jour où on a fermé les
grilles du château on a pensé au jour où
on allait les rouvrir et donc c'était
effectivement une joie mais c'était
aussi assez émouvant de penser à tout ce
que nous avions partagé et vécu ensemble
pour recommencer à j'allais dire à vivre
parce que c'est aussi un symbole la
réouverture du château de versailles
c'est le symbole que la vie reprend que
l'activité reprend bien sûr à versailles
mais bien au delà de versailles du point
de vue des visiteurs pour le moment vous
devez vous passez des étrangers qui
représentent pourtant 80% mais visiteurs
et oui absolument mais de toute façon je
crois qu'on est tous évidemment dans
cette situation est d'ailleurs dans tous
les pays c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
les échanges entre nos pays se sont
arrêtés et ce qui est tout à fait
nouveau c'est que habituellement si
j'ose dire quand un pays vivait une
crise est bien tous les autres pouvaient
compenser et venir à leur place est
aujourd'hui bien nous n'avons plus de
chinois plus de d'américains est pour
l'instant plus d'européens n'ont plus
j'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir bientôt
revenir
france pour partager l'été avec nous au
moins mais effectivement c'est une
nouvelle manière d'ouvrir le château de
versailles et c'est une manière de dire
aux français d'écouté venet à versailles
parce que vous allez retrouver sûrement
un château que vous aviez peut-être
oublié parce que souvent on vient aversa
quand on est enfant et puis on y revient
avec ses propres enfants et parfois
entre deux on va ailleurs on va à
l'étranger
et bien cette année puisque nous ne
pourrons pas voyager n'est les analysons
je pense que nous pourrons revenir ici
et découvrir tout ce qui a été fait
pendant toutes les années passées à
versailles
tout ce que nous ouvrons on a ouvert une
soixantaine de pièces depuis 8 ans ont
créé des parcours dans les jardins cette
année vous pourrez découvrir le parcours
des arbres admirable dans les jardins
mais aussi le parcours des statuts
remarquable puisque on ne sait pas
toujours que le château de versailles
c'est aussi un musée de plein air avec
quelques 400 statues et donc nos
conservateurs ont mis à profit ce temps
du confinement pour faire un parcours
magnifique et qui permettra de découvrir
les jardins à travers et au rythme des
statuts 12 et un appel aux français mais
le public était présent dès ce week-end
tous les créneaux réservés
oui je crois que les français étaient
ravis d'être ici mais parce que versait
fait partie intégrante de leur histoire
est que justement venir à versailles
s'est montré que comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure non seulement que la vie
reprend mais qu' on partage aussi cette
histoire ensemble
le château de versailles accompagné
l'histoire de la france quand il ne l'a
pas fait et on constate qu'à chaque
événement heureux ou malheureux on parle
de versailles et pour les événements les
plus tragiques d'entre eux je pense par
exemple à la première guerre mondiale
la première chose qui recommence ce sont
les fontaines pour les grandes eaux dans
les jardins de versailles
et bien sûr il ya aucune comparaison à
faire mais c'est un petit peu ce que
nous avons vécu le week end dernier avec
des visiteurs qui étaient très heureux
de revenir versailles et qui nous le
disait et qui remerciait aussi les
agents pour le travail qu'il faisait et
ça c'est une grande satisfaction pour
nous tous mais vous avez dû revoir un
petit peu toute l'organisation il faut
notamment réservés quatre mille cinq
cents par jour on est quand même très
loin des plus de 25000 que vous
accueillez oui bien sûr mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut changer de regard a
changé de point de vue
en tous les cas pour quelques mois
j'espère pas trop longtemps
mais pendant quelques mois il faut
s'habituer à vivre avec des formats de
visites plus petits mais aussi peut-être
plus d'une certaine manière plus
agréable pour ceux qui vont faire les
visites
je pense que cette jauge nous n'allons
pas la garder éternellement mais pour
l'instant effectivement on ouvre les
portes de versailles d'une autre façon
puisque on emprunte un vaste couloir qui
permet de de se promener à travers les
appartements royaux mais en même temps
en étant assez concentré sur ce qu'on
fait et donc cette visite à mon avis
reprend des couleurs différentes pour
ceux qui connaissent bien versailles
dans les visiteurs qui viennent ces
jours ci il y a évidemment les les
abonnés les habitués ceux qui habite non
loin d'ici et qui retrouve versailles et
qui disent ah mais j'avais pas remarqué
peut-être tableau parce que peut-être
que j'étais un petit peu trop pressés
que j'allais trop vite et est finalement
là dans cette nouvelle configuration
et bien ils font de nouvelles
découvertes et c'est très bien vous
allez avoir des visites guidées qu'on
pourrait presque qualifier de priver
absolument puisque les poulets nombre
des visites
enfin les nombre de participants à une
visite privée ont dû être diminuée et
donc ses visites privées qui permettent
de voir des appartements qu'on ne
verrait pas autrement parce qu'ils sont
trop exigus et bien vont effectivement
fournir là aussi à nos visiteurs
l'occasion de faire des découvertes qui
pour eux seront sans doute très
extraordinaire parce que ici à chaque
fois que vous pouvez c'est une porte
c'est une histoire qui se raconte où
vous regardez tableau est bien derrière
lui a aussi le travail d'un artiste
meubles c'est le travail d'un ébéniste
les tissus qui sont souvent évidemment
magnifique et bien évoque des métiers
qui quelquefois disparaîtrait si
versailles n'existait plus donc c'est
simplement je crois qu'il faut toujours
dire que versailles c'est le passé et le
présent et c'est ce grand patrimoine qui
nourrit la création qui nourri notre
imaginaire et qui fait que nous avons
envie de le retrouver et on verra aussi
que les équipes n'ont pas chômé pendant
ces jours de confinement
oui c'était d'abord parce que nous
étions peu nombreux à être sur le site
puisque beaucoup malheureusement devait
être confiné ont dû faire du travail à
distance et beaucoup de travail à
distance et puis on a essayé de
maintenir la vie au ralenti peut-être
mais de maintenir la vie au château de
la saq pour que ce château d'agassac pou
puisse ouvrir ses portes et revivre sans
qu' il y est tout à refaire par exemple
c'est extrêmement banal mais il fallait
faire le ménage donc l'entretien a été
fait de façon à ce que lorsque le
château de versailles allait ouvrir ses
portes et bats la galerie des glaces
apparaître est insolente peut-être
encore plus que les années passées
puisque ce grand ménage n'avait pas été
fait dans la galerie des glaces depuis
merci à catherine pégard êtes la
présidente de l'établissement public de
versailles et donc le château est ouvert
la réservation est conseillée surtout
n'oubliez pas vos masques elle va
représenter les yvelines au concours
mills internationale à la mi-juillet
adeline cortesi est passionné par les
concours de beauté depuis son enfance
pour espérer se qualifier en finale
mondiale la plaisir oise doit trouver un
costume représentant son département le
portrait signé michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
adeline cortesi 25 ans 1 m 78 fait
partie des 60 finalistes pour miss
international france cette plaisir oise
originaire de château fort a réussi le
casting en mars dernier au niveau
régional pour participer à ce concours
de beauté créé en 1960 internationale
c'est un grand concours de beauté
international qui est classée 3e
concours mondial après miss univers et
miss monde et donc tous les ans il ya
une représentante de la france qui part
à cette élection représenter notre beau
pays et bien sûr si je pouvais ramener
une couronne à la maison ce serait une
grande joie pour essayer de remporter
cette couronne adeline cortesi va tenter
de miser sur son expérience dans le
monde de la beauté
c'est un milieu que j'ai toujours un
petit peu suivi étant plus jeune j'ai
fait un petit peu de mannequinat et
voilà avec les années je me suis dit que
ce serait intéressant de toucher aussi à
ce milieu des miss
j'ai déjà participé à une élection il ya
deux ans et donc cette année j'ai
souhaité réitérer l'expérience
pour ce concours les participants
doivent notamment trouver une tenue
représentant leur région leur
département
la miss est aujourd'hui en séance
d'essayage dans cette boutique
versaillaise sélectionné 3 adeline
cortesi a choisi de s'inspirer du xviiie
siècle et du château de versailles
ayant grandi dans un village tout proche
de versailles
j'ai trouvé que c'était un clin d'oeil à
ces sympathiques à mon enfance et donc
j'ai contacté cette jolie boutique qui
crée des costumes versaillais et donc
voilà une de ses robes ce sera mon
costume régional pour l'élection est
tenue qui pourrait faire la différence
lors de la finale nationale à roubaix le
12 juillet prochain en cas de victoire
adeline s'envolera pour le japon afin de
représenter la france
cette information pour terminer peut
être une bonne nouvelle pour les férus
du septième art le cinéma le grenier à
sel rouvrira le mercredi 1er
et attrapes annonce aujourd'hui de la
municipalité sur son compte twitter pour
rappel le gouvernement autorisait les
salles obscures à accueillir de nouveaux
du public à partir du 22 juin
attrape la salle sera limité à 50% de sa
capacité entrées et sorties indépendante
un nettoyage sera effectué à chaque
séance et une réservation en ligne est
conseillé voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi et très
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]